can you guys tease the most oMG moment
of this season we both have to oMG
moments on the show and hers is gonna be
physical pain and mine's gonna be like
life-altering big deal big deal in my
life a little problems at all inter
tangle into one big problem right and
the problem still hangs there now it's
not Tom christina is my favorite person
in the whole world
I almost wish christina lived closer
because five houses is a little too far
away and the young hotter version of you
well we do you have newer parts but they
are fake we have to talk about season
two of smothered what was it like being
a part of season 1 so much so that you
were like sign me up for another one
let's do this again
well you know season 1 was you know
scary it was new and but but when season
2 came along it just seems so natural
and normal and we loved our producers
and TLC all the people are so nice they
became like family to us I could say it
when they leave she gets very like
emotional she smothers everybody so she
did like I mean we love having them and
it really did just seem natural
I just kind of we didn't even question
it we were like sure so it's become
second nature to you guys to have you
know a clue of you know five to 10
people however many it is you know
holding the boom and the camera you you
like having all those people around well
it's amazing because once they're around
like it it's like you know it doesn't
you don't even realize they're very sick
what they're taping you don't know when
they're taping when they're not taping
so you just live life as it goes and we
just do it organized right shoot did
they just get that camera you know it's
always interesting
I think when people have reality shows
that the kids are involved in Christine
is that a conversation you had with your
husband and you guys kind of like
mutually came to the agreement or are
there any rules about the kids there's
actually not because I grew up like my
mom like kids don't have a say they
don't have a choice they have to do
whatever mom and dad says so it's kind
of like my husband and I agreed we were
on board so I'm too bad two kids just
and the kids I mean I always loved them
like
yeah my daughters are very much into my
son he's not so much into it so he no
back away or he just won't be in a scene
I don't ask him to it's totally fine but
my daughter's love it I know that my
relationship with my mom does get on my
husband's nerves I don't even know why
you're involved in this whole situation
I definitely knew what he was getting
into with the two of us you've got a
tease what do we have in store for
season two what are you most excited for
fans to see well season two starts off
obviously you see that I'm doing a
remodel of my home she wants us to move
in with her which something my husband
is not about so you will see what goes
down it there will be a very big
surprise that happens and naturally I
want to pick everything in our new house
and you know they're not happy about
that she is putting her input in which I
love but my husband doesn't but you see
a very big surprise I mean I have to
tell you I mean definitely have to tune
in and watch I been taking showers with
Brittany since she was 5 in the mornings
like walking home and I just liquor all
up my puppy I have saved all of Sarah's
baby teeth they smell so beautiful
there's some new mother daughters that
are joining the show this season and
their storyline these are quite shocking
what do you make of all these new moms
have you had a chance to meet them and
spend time with them no we never get to
meet we've never met any of the mothers
and daughters but you know the things
that happen did we don't do that kind of
stuff you know whatever whatever people
want to do I am for anything but yeah
who are we to judge the best friend
relationship you know and it took a long
it takes a long time to get here my mom
who's a mother for my whole life growing
up and once I got married she made a
switch and she was like I can be your
best friend I'm not going to judge
anybody whatever you do when you're
having a good time god bless but you do
everything together I mean we do things
we should do it once we do fun stuff I'm
not
yes you're naked
this show is such a hot-button show and
people love to talk about it whether
they loved it or they find it a little
bizarre what do you say to the critics
who think that this is just insane and
that you guys have an unnatural
relationship I really don't understand
that when people say that to us because
I can't it's not to me it's not a
natural to me mothers and daughters who
aren't together all the time or mothers
that aren't calling their daughters that
aren't calling their mothers for advice
to me that's not normal so I can't even
relate to that we don't find our
relationship so extreme we find it
normal and we enjoy each other's company
and my best friend that's right I am
can you guys tease the most oMG moment
of this season it's something that her
painful something that was painful like
what is a pain or emotional pain
physical pain we both have two oMG
moments on the show and hers is gonna be
physical pain and mine's gonna be like
life-altering I never did before so it's
something I tried that I had never done
and I did it and in her okay my brain
goes to a million places did you get
something waxed did you go skydiving she
did keeping to herself I did something
to myself yeah are you doing okay today
oh I'm fine I was fine you know ten
minutes later it was just at the moment
it's just the initial has there ever
been a moment during production while
you're filming where something got too
personal too heated too intense where
you said I need five stop the cameras
I feel like there was something there
yeah when you through the dream I can't
believe that we didn't you know expect
that to happen and nor do we want that
on camera and let people think that
she's this crazy woman you know by doing
some PDL but he just aggravated me but
and the thing was we were so upset
during it that we didn't even look to
tell the cameras like stop or whatever
we just ran into the bathroom just fine
sad so it just turned him now yeah one
of those things what Cathy what was the
reaction to that did you get hate on
social media or people coming up to you
a lot of people said that was so funny a
lot of people was like oh yeah that was
great
you know it was it was very mixed very
mixed um yeah you know I apologized like
I said before there was alcohol involved
and you know I probably wouldn't have
done that but it was the heat of the
moment but mm you know when you're when
you're doing this all kinds of things
get caught on tape I mean and we don't
know what's getting aired we never we
don't know we don't get to see anything
prior to it 3 when we see it these were
like oh no shoot I forgot I said dad
what was your reaction when you watched
that back on TV I needed it yeah she
hated I hated it do you I was not what
is your relationship with Christina's
in-laws and Carlo like today I just
follow along side her whatever she is
she's in I'm in it she's out I'm out you
know and I read Carlo a lovely child but
as far as the rest of the family I'll be
fine with them if they're fine with that
Christina where's your relationship at
with them my husband is great with his
family unfortunately it's not and you
might get a little glimpse towards the
end of this season what's going on
unfortunately we have the kind of
relationship that has ups and downs we
talk and then there's months they go by
that we don't speak and it's an
unfortunate for the kids who are cousins
which hey it hurts me to see that but
you know we do what we can't Christina
UT is that something
life altering is happening to you this
season what does that it's not gonna
come to the end so you're you're gonna
have to watch big deal big deal in my
life changes all of our lives a little
bit so I mean it happen does it change
the way that you're living today not
today
I just need to know in what arena that
falls is it a family problem is it a
problem between you and your husband
all that's together there there will be
problems family my husband not there's
there's a big big problem a little
problems at all inter tangle into one
big problem right and the problem still
hangs there now it's not time it's not
sold yet so being in the limelight and
being part of this really fun and
entertaining reality TV scene are you
friendly with any of the other TLC stars
or housewives or anybody just on
unreality TV is there someone that you
look to for advice or you'd love to have
a career like I've always loved the
Housewives of New Jersey Melissa first
started received she came to Chicago and
we went to a czar yeah well they just
don't happened Joe Gorga on grabbed my
son who was this big and he said give me
that baby right now I gotta take a
picture with him they were so nice and
Melissa's sister was there they were so
great I mean if you could have her and
she was so excited Melissa like do you
want to have a book or a boutique like
what is the goal with all this newfound
fame that you guys have my pictures to
get on Dancing with the Stars she it's
always been Ryan talk about that to show
of her era that would be my dream come
true I'm just a mom I'm not looking to
be a star or anything like that I'm just
a mom I go with the flow you know rocks
are ready yeah you know did they say I
look like gene Simmons I don't know they
give her a lot of I get a lot of a lot
of that a lot of grief or yeah
I mean do you guys read the comments did
I get to you know are we we we don't but
does it get to me no way
don't laugh at yourself if you can't
laugh at yourself is there one comment
that sticks out in your mind that really
got you well it's mostly about my hair
but I do have very bad hair I understand
that you know it's constant about my
hair in my eyeliner too old I shouldn't
be wearing my hair like this
socha truth is and this is something you
know she does have hair loss right now
I'm like bald when people don't know so
I like use hair in the can and stuff you
know I should be telling you this but I
like a bald person so it's kind of
hurtful a turtle from new phase right
pours out about her because they don't
actually know what her problem sorry
tell everybody I'm fault I don't care
you know I do the best I can to cover it
up
[Music]